こんにちははじめ社長ですはいというわけで今ですねアバンティーズハウスに入るん
ですけどもかこの動画で彼ほど覚えてるよ
iphone を天ぷらにする動画お株を奪ったんですけども
ばいばい
僕の iphone に変えてそれを天ぷらに上げて本人は自分の iphone が
天ぷらにされたっていう驚いちゃったっていうドッキリだったんですけども今回はそれ
の macbook バージョンやろうと思いますどうやったらサーチの
macbook を天ぷらにできるかってゆる考えてず macbook のボックっ
ていうのはないですなかったんだから本物の macbook やるしかないと思って
かといって自分で macbook を壊すのもちょっともったい
ないした所大炎上するじゃないですかだからとりあえずまくる壊さずにどうやったら
育ちも macbook を天ぷらに出ているかと思った時にこちらを手に入れました
こちらなんと
ジャンク品の macbook でございますはもうわざわざネットで探しまくって
完全に振っ壊れてもどうしようもない macbook を見つけましたごらん
ください亀ばもう割れてってほんとじゃん
だからねトラックパッド飛びすぎでしょこれはもう行くなり焼くなり好きにしていい
macbook などで本当にこの完全にジャンクと化したバッグ book を
天ぷらにしますこれがジャンクの macbook
どっちが更地上がって受ける思いますね安全時期がもう奇跡的にシール貼ってないって
いう
しかも4まだまだしたしますというわけでえともう
真っ直ぐさが違いなから帰ってくるんですけどもうまいことを彼にバレないような
タイミングにマグブックを擦り帰って僕がバーンってバーンて持って行って天ぷらにし
てあれの反応を見てみようと思いますから
とりあえず1
テンペラの準備
いいいいいいいいいい
[音楽]
ええええええ
に紹介したいん
[音楽]
蔵王者凡退と思います
ふーん
チェッカーコードが入っている
はいはいはい
わー
[音楽]
マダラ費を充てこれから
んはったん
can you do
[音楽]
それをだよわぁ
ん
ni
応募わぁあああああああ
ません
pale ale
ああああ
ああああああ
re re j wall e
wh
俳句いい
食べられます
持っています
本当に御苦労じゃんこれ1点日てかけて偽物でした
こっちああ
[音楽]
me
ううううううエイ
car
uh